j'ai eu un avis d'explosion chaque année
près de 250 000 Québécois ont recours à
l'aide juridique c'est un filet social
important dans notre système de justice
pourtant il y a encore beaucoup de
préjugés et on pense souvent qu'on est
des avocats de deuxième classe pour des
citoyens une deuxième classe
puis ça pourrait pas être plus faux
alors ce matin me dire
qui est accusé de meurtre au premier
degré de la série documentaire à ma
défense permet de découvrir le quotidien
d'avocat passionnés qui ont choisi de
travailler à la juridique
on est là pour aider des gens qui sont
souvent dans les périodes les plus
noires de leur vie qui qui souvent pas
juste un problèmement quand quand une
première brique tombe souvent le mur
suit puis on est là pour essayer de les
aider on a un côté je pense il y a un
côté travail social aussi à ce qu'on
fait je pense que c'est inévitable ce
que j'ai fait pour toi dans le passé
juriste en droit civil ou en droit
criminel on suit le travail de
séjouriste qui ont la tâche complexe de
défendre les plus vulnérables de notre
société dans des causes extrêmement
variées
devient il y a des circonstances de la
vie qui font en sorte qu'on a des
problèmes puis qu'on est appelé à
venir au palais de justice par exemple
ou à la Cour municipale vous ça fait
combien de temps que vous habitez là
à ma défense permet aussi de découvrir
des histoires humaines touchantes et des
parcours de vie cabossés de certains des
justiciables qui ont recours à la
juridique tout le monde a droit à une
défense pleine et entière c'est un droit
qui est garanti par l'achat des droits
et libertés canadiennes
certaines histoires sont dures et
entendre mais ces avocats plaident sans
jugement ce que j'ai beaucoup aimé quand
j'ai rencontré les
avantages juridiques c'est le feu la
passion qui les habitait moi ça m'a
vraiment beaucoup charmé et c'est de
voir leur engagement auprès des
populations vulnérables je trouvais que
c'était beau c'est une belle vocation
à l'heure où les avocats de l'Algérie
renégocient leur convention collective
ils espèrent que cette série permettra
au grand public et au décideurs de mieux
comprendre leur réalité ici bien
Alexandre Chartier Radio-Canada Montréal